republican senator tom cotton of
arkansas joins us now from capitol hill
senator good morning good morning i want
to talk about daca and of course i know
you have a bill to address that are you
willing to grant those 800 000 children
legal status and what needs to be done
to achieve that
well first i want to say that president
trump took the right step yesterday
president obama's executive order was
illegal he said he didn't have the
authority before he issued it and he
said when he did issue it it was
temporary
but that said president trump is trying
to deal with the situation in the most
orderly way possible he can't defend
that order in court but he wants
congress to take action and i've talked
to him and i've said that i'm happy to
help try to forge some kind of
compromise if we're going to give legal
status though to these young people in
their 20s and 30s who are here through
no fault of their own we have to
recognize that's going to have negative
consequences it's going to open up a
whole new category of people who could
get legal status namely their parents
who violated the law by bringing them
here and it's going to encourage other
people to bring their children across
the border in the future which is a very
dangerous thing to do so my legislation
the raise act would stop unlimited
family chain migration addressing the
first problem and then enhanced
enforcement measures would address the
second problem that's a straightforward
and targeted package that doesn't try to
boil the ocean or solve every problem
but solves the problem right in front of
us
do you have any indication that
president trump supports your bill or
that the senate majority leader supports
your bill
well president trump and i uh along with
senator perdue my co-sponsor i had an
event last week
or last month at the white house where
we introduced the bill president trump
also
cited our legislation in his statement
yesterday
rescinding president obama's unlawful
order so he strongly supports it and
i've discussed with senator mcconnell my
efforts to try to help solve the
immediate problem in front of us but
also mitigate the harms of taking that
action congress has tried congress has
tried to pass a big sweeping immigration
bill three times in the last 11 years
it's failed every time it's time that we
take a different incremental common
sense approach which leads me to my
question where you said it's failed
every time it's heartbreaking looking at
the daca recipients who are really very
frightened they're terrified they're
marching in the streets the people that
love and care of them care about them
they really are in legal limbo so how
confident are you that this time
congress can get this done knowing
what's at stake well again if we address
this specific problem in front of us i'm
confident that we can part of the
problem has been that democrats for many
years have not wanted to take this
incremental measured step because they
wanted to try to tie up legal status for
the six to eight hundred thousand
twenty or thirty senators that leads us
right back to where we started the
democrats blame the republicans the
republicans blame the democrats so i
know you've had conversations with your
colleagues have there been real
heart-to-heart conversations about what
we're going to do to make sure this time
we get it done forget about the past we
now have to look to the future
well
actually there's plenty of blame to go
around to both parties on this and
failures three times over the last 11
years but no i've had conversations with
my democratic colleagues and you really
can't dispute just as a logical matter
that if we give legal status to these
people in their 20s and 30s that it is
going to encourage more illegal
immigration and it will open up legal
status for the very people who violated
the law so we should have an open and
common sense discussion about that and
try to solve those specific problems my
legislation the raise act does that and
say employment verification to make sure
that business owners aren't hiring
illegal immigrants will help address
that as well those are all details
though that we can negotiate if we sit
down and we focus on this specific
problem not everything under the sun
when it comes to immigration all right
senator tom cotton thank you very much
for your time appreciate it